as we wait to see whether Donald Trump
will be arrested and indicted in New
York we have new news out of Georgia
that there may be potential racketeering
and conspiracy charges there coming
against the failed former president
Donald Trump this is again the belief
about mounting legal troubles without
yet even knowing whether the New York
indictment is going to happen now before
I get into this CNN report about what we
have learned I want to remind people
that one of the possibilities if and
when the New York indictment of trump
comes down which Trump said would be
today certainly not seeming like it's
going to be today but we will follow it
one of the reactions was it's kind of a
weak charge it's not the strongest
charge that could be made against Trump
and I agreed with that and the Hope was
that we know there have been prosecutors
who despite having great evidence
against Trump have been hesitant to be
the first to indict a sitting or former
president and that now a former
president is it possible that the Stormy
Daniels charges will break the levy and
then we will see other indictments come
in that's the hope and if that's the
case CNN reports that Georgia
prosecutors are considering racketeering
and conspiracy charges and this is all
related to Trump's effort to overturn
the results in Georgia in the 2020
election where of course Joe Biden won
because Joe Biden received more votes
CNN reports
Atlanta area prosecutors are considering
racketeering and conspiracy charges
Fulton County district attorney fani
Willis could make decisions on charges
this spring Willis will bring her
charging recommendations to the
regularly seated grand juries each
serving two-month terms two regular
grand juries were seated in March the
next batch will be sworn in in May
investigators have at least three
recordings of trump pressuring Georgia
officials including a phone call that he
made to the Georgia house speaker to
push for a special session to overturn
Democrat Joe Biden's 2020 Victory
there's also a recording of Trump's call
to a top investigator with the Georgia
Secretary of State's office where they
were looking into quashed allegations or
of irregularities with signature
matching and then of course Willis
kicked off the investigation soon after
the infamous January phone call wherein
Trump pressures Brad raffensberger to 5
find the votes necessary for him to win
this is the next layer mediaite also
reporting Trump's legal woes go from bad
to worse as CNN reports potential Ricoh
charges for pressuring Georgia election
officials so what do I believe is going
to happen I have no idea
as I've said for a long time
I believe indictments are plausible and
prison time is essentially an
impossibility for Donald Trump I've
explained why numerous times so I won't
do it here this is very serious stuff
there's no doubt that these are
potentially very serious charges at the
same time many of you like me have been
stuck in this sort of time Loop where
we're always close to possible charges
possible charges stemming from this or
that blatant violation of the law that
we read about and yet quote nothing
happens on the one hand I feel that
frustration I share that frustration and
there is a feeling that this is yet just
never going to happen on the other hand
when you speak to Legal experts they do
say these things take a while uh often
times when you look at white-collar
Crimes by non-presidents just by you
know a CEO of a tech company or a banker
or whatever the case may be it can take
years to build these cases here we're
talking about a man who was and is now a
former sitting president and so the
timeline is not actually that unusual
it's just that in most cases we're not
following investigations and we're not
aware of possible charges until much
closer to when those charges are
announced so I am not really taking a
position as to whether I do or don't
think any particular indictment or
charge or arrest is going to happen
Trump said he was getting arrested today
it doesn't seem like it's happening and
now the discussion is about either
tomorrow or next week I don't know I
remain convinced convinced that Trump
will never see the inside of a prison
cell and the the big picture of that is
that at the very worst case if there
were a plea or a guilty verdict
and there were to be confinement uh
allocated or
assigned to trump it would be served as
home confinement I think that that is
the absolute worst case scenario but
we're not even at that step yet we are
now at the step of there are four at
least major investigations into Trump
will any of them lead to an indictment
or an arrest we may know within hours we
may know tomorrow we may know next week
but the big news from the last 24 hours
is whatever happens with this New York
Stormy Daniels hush money case it is not
the end of the line as Georgia I have
believed is the strongest case for a
while now and it seems as though the
most serious charges could indeed come
from there leave me a comment let me
know at this point of in time in your
heart of hearts
what do you expect is coming
as I've mentioned before I supplement my
diet with vitamins every day I've tried
different methods none have been simpler
or more cost effective than just a daily
scoop of ag1 from our sponsor athletic
greens with the one scoop I get the 75
high quality vitamins and minerals from
whole food sources that I want I'm
covered for the day I'm not messing
around with different vitamin capsules
and then some have 200 and some have 180
so they run out at different times and
it's a mess it's a mess this is simple
The Taste is good you can put it in
water juice or shakes each serving is
under three bucks a day compare that to
what all of the individual supplements
would cost you and it just makes sense
simplify your life by starting the day
with a scoop of 75 high quality
nutrients when you go to athletic
greens.com
you'll get a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D before and
five free travel packs of ag1 the link
is down below